all right well thank you for coming
tonight or tonight I'm used to saying
tonight because you know
we have these lectures in the evening
Thursday evenings but I see that a
number of you have noticed you know how
it is that for the last of these
lectures we moved and we had to move
because because ed Racine had some
difficulty now just in getting his visa
to come over and join us but I'm so glad
that he did he really didn't brings a
unique perspective to this series of
lectures this summer on religious
violence and apocalyptic movements he's
really lived a lot of this history
personally as many of you already know
he's the author of the Islamist and this
was a finalist for the George Orwell
Prize for political writing and since
then he's established himself as one of
the most astute and and convincing
commentators on Islamism on with hobby
ISM on the whole series of conflicts
alas that has beset the Muslim world and
I have to say and many of you also know
this is that he is also very courageous
commentator on these issues and somebody
who's been condemned and worse than
condemned both from the left and from
the right but I think that he's a
particularly eloquent spokesman for the
very basic fundamental principle when
people for instance will accuse him of
being an agent of one power or another
even the British government he will
point out that no it is in a democracy
it is the government that is our agent
and as citizens we need to hold it
accountable and so in in all these ways
it's really an honor to have Andrew
staying with us tonight I could go on
about as many other credentials you can
read about them in the the buyer that
you have in front of you but let me just
stuff finally say before we turn things
over to him that I also want to thank
Roger her talk for making all this
possible
Roger her target made the funds
available to support the Hertog global
strategy initiative and the really
exciting research a lot of our students
have been able to do over the course of
the summer so thank you Roger
so over to you
thank you Matt for that very kind
introduction thank you to all of you for
making time on hot Friday afternoon I'm
sure there are a whole host of other
things that you could be doing here in
New York but thank you for making time
and thank you to whoever runs the
Twitter account here for the Hertog
project I mean I keep meeting regular
reminders I've had them for the last
sort of three or four weeks that I'm
supposed to be here today speaking not
that I needed reminding on Twitter on
Twitter but thanks to whoever's the
social media guru here do you do a
splendid job I'm going to speak about
two things broadly two themes first is
that what is al Qaeda because too often
over the last year a year and a half and
maybe longer people have dismissed the
the threat levels posed by Al Qaeda and
secondly I want to talk about
developments on the ground in other
words furnishing you with evidence as to
what I'm talking about and it's not just
doom and gloom and I hope it's not doom
and gloom but to start with then it's
worth saying that al Qaeda isn't some
kind of cooperation with bin Laden who
was at the top and now that bin Laden's
been removed being killed being brought
to justice that our power that is
somehow weaker today or perhaps a better
way of putting it is al Qaeda central at
the helm may well be weak operationally
but my point is that al Qaeda is not an
organization with a strict hierarchy and
further today in the hearts and minds of
millions of people around the world
means more than a strict organization it
means a form of rebellion it's an idea
it's a mass movement it's a world view
it's a brand it's a philosophy you can
buy into it from any part of the world
depending on your adopting a set of
ideas or not I will articulate those
ideas for you in a moment but it's worth
remembering that if you're looking for
you know 20 guys in the Hindu Kush
mountains and you think you're going to
eliminate those 20 guys and therefore al
Qaeda that's eliminated you've got
another thing coming that's not the way
al Qaeda has were
it's not the way it was set up to work
it's it draws legitimacy and its
existence from a whole set of ideas
religious melee or a political mindset
of grievances and as I say I'll coming
to those on to those on in a minute now
the second point to remember is that al
Qaeda never sought to be a mass movement
al Qaeda will not be competing in
elections al Qaeda will not be putting
forward a presidential candidate in any
of the post Arab Spring countries what
al Qaeda is about is ensuring that the
ideas the world view that it espouses
has a legitimacy and B representation in
the political sphere and see most
importantly implementation and in the
absence of Al Qaeda's understanding of
Sharia being implemented in
muslim-majority countries what Al Qaeda
will do is to continue to agitate from
the sidelines from the margins to ensure
the center responds to what al Qaeda
wants and again in a moment we'll
receive will you know I'll bring
evidence for what I'm saying as to how
al Qaeda wants to interact with the
political and religious center of Muslim
societies post Arab Spring now there's
no doubt about the fact that the al
Qaeda was a huge the the Arab Spring or
the Arab uprisings were a serious blow
to al Qaeda's narrative for and here
again I'm not talking about in the
founding of al Qaeda in the 1990s but
the jihadi Salafi worldview the
worldview that thinks that removing
people in political office in other
words killing Anwar Sadat of Egypt or
trying to assassinate people in
political office is legitimate is one
way of removing an obstacle before they
can create the kind of government they
want to create that whole worldview has
been around with us since 1953 onward if
not earlier and I mentioned fifty-three
because of site ah tube in Egypt I don't
want to get distracted with all that but
it's just worth remembering that there
was a whole series of ideas before the
emergence of al Qaeda in the in the
1990s
now this desire to interact with the
political center is is based on several
ideas and the ideas are important
because these I
derived legitimacy from two things one
theology and religious evidence and two
politics so what are these key ideas
that al-qaida central would advocate
al-qaeda the foot soldiers around the
world will embrace al-qaeda supporters
around the world would want to see in
some form of implementation or embrace
in the world and what are these ideas
that whether it's a to put up in the
1950s or where there is a abdesalem
Farraj in the 1970s before he was killed
in 1982 or whether it's the is the Saudi
Salafi Wahabi extreme elements and I'm
not saying all Saudi Salafis are extreme
there are some that aren't but many are
what are these ideas that they advocate
that they wish for muslims to adopt that
they wish that are represented by the
political center post Arab Spring the
the the first idea is what they consider
to be their interpretation of Sharia
being state law in other words Sharia is
not just about ritual observation of
faith but it must be implemented as
state law in the absence of Sharia being
staked law Muslims are sinful and if
Muslims are sinful Muslims are going to
hell if Muslims are going to hell there
must be a group of community group of
Muslims among the global Muslim
community that reminds us that Sharia
must be implemented as state law now
this part of the narrative of this part
of al-qaeda's claim that Sharia must
equate state law has been negated since
at least you know a hundred years after
the Prophet Muhammad by a whole host of
Muslim scholars during the Q&A we can go
through that but what's interesting here
is there are multiple interpretations of
Sharia as state law whether we're
looking at the Shia persuasion the Sufi
persuasion the various Sunni persuasions
or whether for those of you who are more
interested in the detail of the subject
the Mikasa the Sharia understanding in
other words the aims of the Sharia the
point I'm making is there is no one
reading of Sharia law that must be
imposed implemented established at the
expense of others to do that is to cut
away from pluralism to do that is to
ignore other interpretations of Islam
and in early Muslim scholarship that was
always discredited discouraged but where
we have a situation with our father
today is that
their interpretation of Sharia must
become state law otherwise we're all
sinful so that's the first idea of the
al-qaeda Thea political appeal that
Sharia must become state law the second
idea is once Sharia becomes state law
that state in al-qaeda's narrative or an
extreme Salafi narrative becomes a
Caliphate or an Islamic state or a
Halawa or some would call a hacky Mia
some would call it though less Lamia you
know depending on you know who you speak
to the the the generic understanding is
it becomes a Caliphate and the problem
with opening up this whole whole
discussion about the caliphate is nobody
among Muslim communities globally is
happy with one interpretation of a
Caliphate or another even when the
Caliphate existed in in in Turkey there
were rival caliphates in India they were
rival caliphates in in Iran and in other
parts of the Muslim majority world
so from al-qaeda's point of view not
only is it incumbent on a religious
level for Muslims to have Sharia at
state law but their version of Sharia a
state law which they then declare as the
caliphate so the whole experiment in
Afghanistan with Muhammad was supposed
to be that he was the new Holly for the
new Amir of the Muslims and with with
bin Laden there was a lot of chewing and
throwing about this whether he was the
ultimate you know a global leader of
Muslims are not you know interesting
sidenote that bin Laden gave allegiance
to mullah omar in Afghanistan under the
Taliban because he legitimately believed
you know he was now the emir or the
leader of the muslims globally so the
need for a caliphate is central to the
al-qaeda narrative the third point and
this is where it gets interesting
because this third element isn't just
al-qaeda central or its foot soldiers
but people who are from a you know a
Wahhabi persuasion mostly from the Gulf
countries and they've been taught this
in school and when I say this sometimes
Saudi friends get upset but this there
is this idea called a Louella wall bara
you know al wala well bara something
that none of us growing up Muslims were
really familiar with but came out of
Saudi Arabia in the 1980s with a real
degree of seriousness and this is an
argument that says Muslims you know
their definition of Muslims are loyal
only to fellow Muslims friendships
economic exchanges preference for
hospital treatment you know everything
must be with you know Muslims first and
only to Muslims and disavowal or
rejection of other communities not just
Christians and Jews but everybody else
you know and I single out Christian and
Jews because of the quranic reference to
them being people of the book or people
who preceded muslims in the Abrahamic
tradition so this you know but are from
them or the rejection of them plays into
this al-qaeda narrative of the demin us
mindset and most Muslims throughout
history and even if you ask the Prophet
Muhammad's companions do you understand
what Allah Allah Allah bara means they
would say no they just it didn't compute
but this is you know a modern idea from
the 80s that's been adopted by al-qaeda
the evidence for that is you know I'm an
asura his most recent statement he talks
about halal but uh he wrote a whole book
about Al Walla Walla Osama bin Laden
spoken at least six different video
statements about unreliable para its
central to the premise of the villainous
worldview that Muslims must put Muslims
first and everybody else falls by the
wayside
of course the consequences of that are
you know you can't open a you know a
pluralist mindset you don't have a
multi-religious Society
you have minorities that are you know
treated as second or third class
citizens there are real consequences for
that argument and we're seeing the
playing out of Allah al bara in Saudi
Arabia today but that's the mile depart
but al Qaeda would take it to its
logical conclusion and say al Allah
Elberon means Muslims can't be part of
the United Nations they've said that
they've said Muslims can't have dealings
with the World Bank in other words
Muslims must create this international
ghetto of Muslims only and you can't do
that in the modern world but that's you
know where the al Ghul evolve are the
third element of del PI the narrative
ends up the fourth element is what they
call takfeer and this is dangerous more
for Muslims than it is for others
because the reason why al Qaeda was
killing more Muslims in in Iraq or Iraq
before the Arab uprisings
was because they justified the killing
of fellow Muslims on the grounds that
you know people like me and others
mainstream I happen to be a Sunni Muslim
that we're not Muslim enough you know
because we don't embrace al-qaeda's
understanding of Allah Allah Allah or
the need for Sharia state law or their
understanding of
calafate as I just outlined them if we
reject those aspects what they what they
then declare us is to be kaffir kafar
non-believers hence the word takfeer
which means to excommunicate to say
we're not Muslims anymore it's on the
basis of this argument this idea of
making thick fear of excommunicating
that they justify the attacks on shrines
in in Iraq the exploding of tombs
recently in Mali or in Libya or the
attacks on the shrines in Pakistan over
the last two years wherever you see
Muslim on Muslim violence almost always
it's justified with this you know
central narrative of Al Qaeda's idiocy
of takfeer in other words saying someone
isn't Muslim in traditional Islam in
Orthodox Islam at the last 1,300 years
declaring someone to be a non-muslim or
to make takfeer on them was a huge deal
it wasn't done so easily so sort of
haphazardly but that's the that's the
that's the norm among Al Qaeda to rendom
fellow Muslims as non-muslims and
therefore justifying their killing and
on those grounds what you know the
killing of Muslims in Iraq and on those
grounds essentially al-qaeda shot
themselves in the foot because now the
stats are that they've killed more
Muslims than they've killed non-muslims
I'm not for a moment justifying killing
of non-muslims but the point is al Qaeda
sees itself as the protector of Muslims
of the defender and the vanguard of
Muslims but it's you know killing fellow
Muslims to make it sir you know advance
its world view the fifth idea of course
for the al Qaeda narrative is jihad in
other words all of these the ideas that
I've mentioned must be advanced by
physical violence in other words if if
you can't implement Sharia state law if
you can't volunteer get a caliphate if
Muslims stand in the way of embracing or
creating this worldview embrace violence
remove them because jihad of physical
violence is justified in order for the
greater good and the greater good here
is to create the Caliphate to impose
Sharia state law and to do what they
call create a call to good and forbid
evil it's so
and then the vi idea underlining all
this and this is perhaps the the part
that you know has been driven home most
in the West is and and all of this has
been going on in muslim-majority
societies since 1953 you know especially
in the arab world but what's what's the
final idea to this al-qaeda narrative is
is its dish had or martyrdom
you know the belief that undertaking
jihad and getting killed in its way or
losing one's own life is to become a
martyr to become a Shaheed to become a
witness in the advance of this cause the
advance of these theological political
ideas that have outlined and to become a
martyr is the most honorable noble
status that they bestow on their dead
but to be fair to them you know it's not
only them this is a this is a phenomenon
in the Arab world that whoever dies for
a political cause becomes a Shaheed and
we've seen that in Syria with both sides
claiming that their dead are martyrs so
and you know martyrdom is is I mean I
you know the when we can we can talk
about this at the Q&A but you know they
don't become martyrs for 72 virgins in
heaven I can assure you of that and but
that seems to be the default
understanding here that it's all about
you know virgins and the heavenly life
the heavenly life aspect is that life
continues in other words their life
doesn't end if you're a martyr but it's
not about you know it's not about
virgins and I can if you ask me the Q&A
session I can maybe go into it more but
so these are the six ideas that drive
that propel al Qaeda now al Qaeda was
born from that Millia
from that intellectual background in al
Qaeda that did not create these ideas
and the death of al Qaeda the death of
Osama bin Laden does not mean the end of
these ideas and yet I give you two
quotes yet just after bin Laden's death
you know Leon Panetta said in July 2011
the United States is within reach of
defeating al Qaeda and is targeting 10
to 20 leaders who are key to the
terrorists Network survival I'm
convinced that we're within reach of
strategically defeating al Qaeda you
know Leon Panetta Fareed Zakaria on
you know at a similar date says al-qaeda
is over the truth is this is a huge
devastating blow to al Qaeda which had
already been crippled by the Arab Spring
for his right it was crippled by the
Arab Spring and but I think you know
he's wrong to say that al Qaeda is over
so these are the key ideas part of the
the political narrative that drives al
Qaeda's appeal among you know millions
of people in in Arab and Muslim majority
societies and if you doubt if you doubt
my claim that he bin Laden or that
narrative has an appeal I put this to
you when Osama bin Laden was killed the
White House John Brennan the morning
after and others went out of the way to
say they would not distribute images of
an of a dead of summer bin Laden you
know they went out of the way and they
said you know I mean their excuse was
you know they just didn't want to
release those pictures now at the same
time on the Arab websites from Al
Jazeera in onward Arab aljazeera Arabic
website and others they were touting the
US and the White House saying well if
you really cook because there was a
denial immediately now it never happened
he's a martyr if it happened and it
never happened he can't have it both
ways that he's a martyr if it happened
and it didn't happen but they did and
what was interesting was they were
saying give us the evidence if bin Laden
is dead show us the evidence and you'll
remember that the Guardian then leaked a
sort of a claimed leak that wasn't elite
but the point I'm making to all of this
is people in Washington DC know that
releasing an image of bin Laden dead
would be offensive to a large
constituency of people in the Arab world
which would then result to greater anger
and anguish and a sense of vengeance
than otherwise not not releasing them
you know so there is a feeling that the
sentiment that this man has an appeal
now again will come to you know some
evidence for the appeal in a moment so
those are the ideas now without doubt
al Qaeda's al Qaeda was dealt a severe
blow with the Arab Spring because al
Qaeda's whole aim was violence and
violent overthrow that method has failed
but I all of the persuasion had they not
tried that method you know
younger Arabs of this generation would
not have gone for the street now they
went for the street knowing that the
previous generation of the 70s and the
80s went for assassinations went for
political killings and they ended up in
prison and then you know chased out of
their countries and you know the
dictators held control over the country
so trying that the democratic method for
younger generation clearly paid off now
that said what's going on post Arab
Spring and I you know speaker's someone
who has been visiting the Arab world
since then I've you know I've been to
Bahrain Saudi Arabia Egypt the
Palestinian territories Israel and I've
been visiting those parts of the world
prior to the Arab Spring and I've lived
in Syria for two years during the Iraq
war lived in Saudi Arabia for about a
year and I've seen the shift and there's
no doubt about the fact that the Arab
Spring is on balance thus far good news
I'm not denying that but we can't be
naive and think that the greater sort of
free public space in those countries
will not then enable others who were
traditionally just put in but and put
behind bars to now emerge and operate in
the in in the open and that's what's
what's happening and I'll just take you
know several countries very quickly with
you first you you're you're all witness
to what's going on in Libya you know the
the blowing up of the shrines and the
militias but also parts of Yemen that
have now been completely taken over in
near about Nia had remote by you know Al
Qaeda's local franchise and Al Qaeda's
clerics such as in Danny hold Swain in
those parts of the country but the three
countries that strike me most and I know
better I'm in Egypt Tunisia and Syria
now Egypt is the hub of the Arab world
eighty two million Arabs the cultural
center the intellectual nerve of the
Arab world and when Osama bin Laden was
killed
there were several mass funeral prayers
for him janazah prayers held in absentia
in a pre arab spring that was
inconceivable that anyone would dare say
that a bin Laden was
you know someone who is a martyr and
being required funeral prayers in Cairo
and in Alexandria with mosques packs
full after Friday prayers and that's
exactly what happened an endorsement of
Osama bin Laden as a Meza martyr and
huge prayers
what problem one problem - right in the
heart of Tahrir Square from day one but
there was imagery of Abdul Rahman the
blind Sheikh who was behind the first
World Trade Center bombing here and we
saw President Morsi you know on balance
he's been good but on this issue he's
been weak you know saying that he would
lobby the US for what Abdul Rahman's
release and to this day on a black man's
people have a huge presence on the on
that I think the most eastern part of
that who I've seen that on the six
visits that I've undertaken public
presence nobody will question it people
won't put it aside and you know major
clerics in the country support that
cause of releasing someone who was an
open advocate and remains to be an open
advocate of endorsing suicide bombing
and attacks on the West and the
mastermind behind the first World Trade
Center attack third and more recently
the Sinai jihadis not just their attacks
or their attempt to did attacks on on
Israel but also their killing of
Egyptian policemen sixteen policemen
being killed on what grounds on the very
grounds that are highlighted earlier
after the belief that they of takfeer
that they're no longer Muslims because
they're serving and non that they're
serving a secular government and they
considered the current government to be
secular and finally in Egypt not just a
silent situation but more broadly if the
30 percent of the first shot of the
parliamentary election was from the
Salafi Brigade now where you have
salafism emerging almost always you have
violent forms of Salafism in emerging
the Egyptian public space has become
more Islamized
when the public space becomes more
Islamized others say it's not Islamic
enough and then they want a more Salafi
form of Islam and from that we see a
more violent form of Islam turn into
Tunisia and Tunisia is important because
Tunisia is the intellectual pioneer of
Islamism
not of the Arab world but of Islamism
and by Islamism I mean the
politicization of Islam in Russia the
minutiae
who's the leader of the Venusian the the
another party is important because he
was he's the only Islamist
who's fully behind women's rights in his
writings who believes in the secular
state but justifies it with Islamic
language and who has more or less made
the best outreach to the West but also
in his country has outlined the need for
maintaining a secular balance and he's
influenced the Turkish a.k party and a
kay party in turn seems to be
influencing the Egyptians so he's an
intellectual vanguard and even there in
his country because Anu she and others
have said that they will not be
implementing Sharia state law amana's or
Hera came out on the 12th of June this
year and reprimanded the Egyptian that
the tunisian another party called on
Tunisians to declare jihad on him on the
unlock the party and cited scholarship
from the past that that more or less
underpins of a knowshe's or the Tunisian
progressive worldview
so even tunisia a liberal letter
relatively liberal tunisia is not immune
from Izawa he and al-qaeda Central's
influence in trying to change where the
direction of the political center is
heading in such in Asia and we can talk
about this again more in more detail at
the Q&A but the third and most
problematic country I think post Arab
Spring isn't Yemen isn't Libya and to
most of our dismay and shop is actually
Syria and I say so because I've lived in
Syria I know the country I know the
clerics the different factions you know
there's the sectarian factions that uh
Louise the Druze this smileys the Sunni
the Shia and the various Christian
denominations for the last thirty years
there was a relative peace in that
country but not anymore and at the
beginning of this revolution it was a
genuine uprising against the dictator
and the warlord that has had a bashar
al-assad Hafez al-assad son no doubt
about its and legitimate uprising but
just as the Egyptian revolution has now
been hijacked by the the Islamists I'm
not saying it's a negative thing I'm
just it was a point of fact just as the
Tunisian uprising is no longer a secular
liberal sort of command from control but
the most soft Islamist of the another
party the Syrian uprising has to my mind
been hijacked by
Salafi jihadi 's um
not suggesting that they're at the
center of events but the most intense
fighting and the most courageous
fighters have come from various Salafi
jihadi outfits there are 30 rebel groups
the Free Syrian Army or the FSA is one
of them and among the rebel groups at
least 16 to 17 of them are Salafi jihadi
fighters Syria today draws people from
across the Arab world you know that the
dead have been identified from not just
Jordan Iraq and Lebanon neighboring
countries or Turkey
but also from Libya a huge amounts of
arm shipments but also from Tunisia and
more worryingly and you know other parts
of the world too which I'll come to in a
moment
Christian Science Monitor report about
two days ago about parts of Syria that
have been freed and now under what's
called a free under what's called free
Syria are implementing Sharia state law
because that's the default understanding
of what they understand it's not you
know it's not freedom and democracy
which was what the initial rebels wanted
but huge areas that the Free Syrian army
controlled are now implementing Sharia
state law to help me go and read the
Christian Science Monitor and see the
the details for yourselves the other
problem in Syria is that unemployment
was nearing 30 to 33 percent before the
uprisings after the uprising that
rocketed because you know security and
stability was no longer available the
state was breaking down what's now
happening is it's a cottage industry of
you know 25 to 30 men getting together
dispatching their family members to say
Jordan or turkey or the refugee camps in
in in in Lebanon the 25 to 30 men then
become Brigade or a catty bar and they
become you know Khattab
soon know the Kitab of women Tamia give
themselves various Salafi sounding names
they then go and kidnap someone who
writes the post office or a school
because officially both of those
categories that are run by the
government so what they're doing is the
kidnapping you know a government
supporter they put this person on a
YouTube video the look we've captured
Assad supporters they work at a post
office they work at a school they work
in you know whichever government
department in nearby and they become the
shabiha of the government operatives
that YouTube footage of kidnapping in a
Assad supporters then finds its way to
the Gulf
in Qatar and Saudi Arabia and it becomes
a ploy for raising funds and huge
amounts of money has through this route
of our Gulf support come into Syria
because of this cottage industry of
jihad of fighting against the Assad
regime and then you know unemployment
becomes employment I got these reports
from people who are funded in London to
run an opposition television channel and
they're so so worried about these
developments that I want to talk about
them publicly because to do so would be
to undermine the Syrian opposition so
that's where the situation seems to be
heading in Syria I I wrote a piece in
National Review recently explaining some
of this so I don't want to go over it in
too much detail but essentially for al
Qaeda and Salafi jihadi Syria is not
Syria they don't recognize the borders
that divide Syria from Jordan from Iraq
from Lebanon from Turkey and elsewhere
for them Syria is what they called
Bellaire the Sham banana sham was a you
know a tract of land that went from
Lebanon to Syria to Jordan all included
Palestine in Israel and there were no
borders and the Prophet prayed you know
he said along a vertical and a fisherman
there were Yemeni now you know bless our
Shambala - am the Prophet visited sham
you know the night journey of the
Prophet through Jerusalem includes
banana sham for al-qaeda this is central
if there's a second country in the
Middle East they want to control more
after Saudi Arabia would be the first
preference it would be banana sham and
it's Syria in from Syria they see Golan
Heights from the Golan Heights they see
Israel from Syria they see Turkey from
Turkey they see Europe from Syria they
see Hezbollah from Hezbollah they see
Iran Syria is absolutely strategically
vital for al Qaeda and if you think al
Qaeda is simply going to walk away from
Syria and I just think we're wrong and
you know whatever happened in Syria the
the situation is that things will sadly
get worse before they get and get better
I'll conclude by saying two things and
that is the one of the huge problems
with Syria isn't that it's just been a
hub full regional jihadis but it's also
been an attractive point for Western
Muslims you know huge numbers of Muslims
from European countries the recent
estimates are up to about 400 have gone
you know across Europe to go and fight
in Syria many of them from Arab
background many of them and but it's
what European Muslims underwent during
Bosnia you know fighting for fellow
Muslims in Bosnia and prior to that in
Afghanistan Syria is fast becoming the
new Afghanistan the new Bosnia and I I
want to sort of finish with a quote from
a recent quote 25th June of this year on
the 25th of June Jonathan Evans the
director general of mi5 in the britain's
intelligence service spoke candidly and
he said this is in contrast to you know
what was said earlier by Leon Panetta
and Fareed Zakaria after bin Laden's
killing Jonathan Evans said today parts
of the Arab world have once more become
a permissive environment for al-qaeda
and he went on to say a small number of
British would-be jihadis are also making
their way to Arab countries to seek
training and opportunities for militant
activity as they do in Somalia and Yemen
some will return to the UK and pose a
threat here and that's in the United
Kingdom now I'm not trying to put the
fear of God in all of you the point I'm
trying to make is if we're aware of this
if we know what's going on out there on
the ground then we can act on it and we
can prevent the spread of this virus and
we can try to contain it within Syria
and try to disarm D radicalize and
disengage those people who are heading
towards that pathway and if we're not
prepared to accept the problem if we
think somehow al Qaeda is our new proxy
against the Assad regime or Al Qaeda is
now our new jihadi allies as we use them
against the Soviets in the past that
this is now you know the Mujahideen are
a good force to get rid of Iran if we
want to ride the al-qaeda tiger again
then you know there are consequences but
if we're prepared to wake up to the
risks and the dangers that we face now
you know going forward we can address
them and help create a better world for
all of us thank you for listening
in your book you mentioned that freedom
of speech enabled the target area and
that you mentioned just now that the
Arab uprisings had given a greater
political space and had allowed for
al-qaeda to have a voice like extremists
to have a voice that perhaps
dictatorship puts in prison so I
wondered therefore if he felt that
dictatorships contained extremism and
contained terrorism and actually freedom
and democracy or an incubator yeah great
question see I mean if the way dictators
desisting work in Ibraheem yeah okay so
the way dictatorships have contained
extremists have only led to extremists
becoming violent extremists and violent
extremists then become wanting to become
martyrs and the evidence for that is
when say to table the author of
milestones in in Egypt wrote against the
Egyptian government in the 1950s and
early 60s
NASA's response was not to engage with
the ideas not to send you know clerics
from you know other Muslim persuasions
to counter those ideas but to hang the
man for writing the book and he died
because of the book being written so no
freedom of speech so this was NASA's
Egypt as a result of what of being
killed others then took the jihad one
step further you know so you know that
kind of containment or killing of
repression of or eliminating freedom of
speech I I don't think is their way
forward because what it does is makes
the problem worse it drives it
underground the advantage to having
freedom of speech is that it's not that
government would would counter it I
think it's the responsibility of civil
society to counter it that it allows
citizens like ourselves to debate to
discuss to ridicule to undermine the
very ideas that are outlined during my
talk and that can't be done unless it's
a free public space
and you know we're in parts of Britain
that has but there were a problem in the
1990s because of the freedom of speech
and because on college campuses if I may
say so you know many of my teachers at
the time would basically think that you
know Hezbollah Herod were or Islamist
extremists were basically you know
today's communists because many of my
you know professors or my generation
students had professors who were in the
50s and were hippies in the 60s they
basically thought that what's wrong with
a bit of radicalism you know Islamist
radicalism suicide bombing this is
today's Marxism of the third world and
let's support it so the problem is when
you start giving them that kind of space
unchallenged then I think it's a real
problem so freedom of democracy yes but
by challenging extremists containing
them really killing them poking that fun
at their ideas and making them
unattractive and I'll end this answer
with one sort of example in Pakistan
huge amounts of sort of satellite
television channels have become the norm
and people are openly allowed to preach
whatever it is they want so the
countries now become a huge problem not
just because the drone attacks but other
issues that have led to he
anti-americanism being the norm now
there are yes Pakistan has been opened
up by pervez musharraf and now there's a
lot of freedom in the air to talk about
what people want to talk about but
there's no counter voice to the default
extremism that's festering in that
country so freedom and democracy I think
is going in the right direction and in
his part of the answer without doubt but
it has a responsibility on citizens to
know you know their rights and what's
wrong and what's right and I just sort
of bring one other example it's
interesting that Muslims from European
countries are rocking up in Syria rocked
up in Bosnia and in Afghanistan but not
from the United States of America
and there's something to be said about
your country in that from a very young
age you inculcate in your students what
the Constitution stands for what
Jefferson was all about I assume and you
know the establishment of religion in
the First Amendment and all of that more
or less addresses the Islamist narrative
from the very beginning you know and
when these ideas pop up in the public
domain citizens you know the u.s. unlike
the UK in other countries
isn't so dependent on government to
steer the debate you know citizens are
ahead and I prepared to shoot you know
shut down extremists anyhow so a few
weeks ago of Peter Bergen came and gave
a very different tenor to this problem
it was sort of like get over it
don't worry about it it's done and you
of course are giving sort of what we've
been hearing down for ten years except
with a new twist Syria etc how do you
account for that discrepancy you know
like and also how do you account for the
assessment of American foreign policy in
the past eight years because one can
sort of see that we have problematic
outcomes emerging from the two wars
we've been involved with which may leave
us with a residue of this for a long
time to come so I'm just curious first
you know like Bergen doesn't agree with
you all with what you just said and I'm
just wondering you know where we're at
on us yeah sure I mean that's the that's
the benefit of freedom right I mean
Peter Bergen is entitled to his view and
his analysis and with all respect to him
you know and I entitled to mine and I
see what I see on the ground I mean I'm
open to the facts being negated but they
can't you know just to cut Syria look at
it today and look at the main actors and
listen Timon as though I heard his
statements and I'm an agreement with
Peter to the extent that you know does
the United States of America face an
imminent threat today like it did on the
10th of September you know 2001 he would
say no I would say you know we don't
know you know because we didn't know on
that 10th of September and these things
are impossible to tell so I wouldn't be
as optimistic as Peter is but at the
same time I'm not suggesting that you
know the West's focus on the same way
that it did on this problem as it did
post 9/11 far from it what I'm saying is
that the you know we're dealing with a
new situation a new world and you know
there are new threats out there and we
can't just negate them and if we do as
we did Priya 9/11 then it'll come back
and bite us in ways that we
hadn't anticipated and it seems wiser
smarter and more prudent to address this
at this junction at this juncture rather
than wait for it to get better so that's
how I addressed the discrepancy and you
know with all respect to Peter I think
his focus was primarily on Afghanistan
and Pakistan and you know if you think
Pakistan is a better place today than it
was 10 years ago you know think again
yeah levels of anti-americanism are at
record high entire political movements
are being founded on the basis of
anti-americanism in the country yes
American foreign policy and drone
attacks are a huge part of that without
doubt but we can explain it for whatever
reasons but the situation is is what it
is
anti-americanism you know is at an
all-time high in Pakistan for for for
all kinds of reasons US foreign policy
the u.s. foreign policy in talking about
it always lands you in trouble is you
know one quarter or another but it would
be naive to say that you know the United
States actions abroad especially in the
Middle East were not somehow linked to
the anger and the wrath and the sense of
grievance that fueled Osama bin Laden
and the al Qaeda narrative and yes
bin Laden's first videos were about the
troop presence in the Gulf countries
immediately after 1991 but I'd say two
things one those grievances are
justified you know whether it's about
the arab-israeli conflict or whether
it's about the drone attacks and the
collateral damage but the question is
the response you know there are ways to
respond to that why is the response then
unlike and say other countries why is
the response suicide bombings why is the
response of killing innocent Americans
why is the response sort of killing
Muslims who are pro-american or side
with liberal ideas you know why the
response could be a whole host of other
things but it's the response that I
think draws on this reservoir of
geopolitical ideas the second point I'd
make is this that those in the Middle
East who make a big deal of Israel's
and and the injustice is that take place
whether it's in the West Bank or in Gaza
or the settlements and I speak as
someone has just come back from this
about six weeks ago again those
grievances are real they are real I'm
not taking undermining them for a moment
but if Israel went away from the Middle
East tomorrow if Israel disappeared you
know what would change in the Middle
East in real terms people's lives how
does that impact the the very reasons
why they went to the streets schools
jobs health care you know
housing the lack of dignity so there is
a tender I'm not saying that's where
you're coming from but there is a
tendency here and the in parts of the
u.s. to want to constantly blame foreign
policy yes foreign policy needs needs
correction without doubt foreign policy
needs greater attunement with the
realities on the ground but foreign
policy alone and it's injustice is on
its own
do not drive al qaeda it's one factor
but it's al Qaeda's own grievance
narrative ie the lack of its Caliphate
the lack of its Sharia state law the
lack of its own all all and Berar
being manifest the lack of its own
outwards jihad regardless of u.s.
foreign policy actions would mean that
it it would still be in business it
would still be in operation and that
being in business may not be as harsh
and as powerful as it is now because of
the fuel that the foreign policy gives
it but regardless of that it will still
be in business so for me grievances and
ideology go side by side could I just
follow up on that and I wish I had asked
Peter Bergen the same question because I
think it's a very fair question to ask
which is you know how would do you
falsify your argument about Al Qaeda
like what kind of evidence would it take
for you to think that al Qaeda really is
a spent force and and yes it's going to
continue as a brand maybe but it's gonna
in terms of the other kinds of concerns
that people would have it really would
pale by comparison with the other kinds
of foreign policy challenges at least
the u.s. faces now that's a really good
question and you know my first response
would be that way in which parts of the
country are sorry which parts of the
world have
either being decommissioned and you know
they've more or less them or less out of
business and two countries come to my
mind ones Libya ones Egypt
Jamarcus Lamia in Egypt and al-jihad in
Egypt both disengaged from violence and
this is in Egypt but also the Libyan
Islamic fighting group in in in Libya
abandoned the al-qaeda narrative
abandoned the worldview of calling for
violence and we know that happened
because they wrote huge volumes you know
of correctives that they put out saying
why they were wrong why they no longer
call towards violence and why they think
that other Muslim interpretations Sunni
mainstream Muslim interpretations were
legitimate and right and we saw that
with the Libyan Islamic fighting group
in Libya and we saw that too with the
the leader of Gamal Islamiyah and all
jihad in Egypt in the prisons now that
happened as a result of the Islamic
leadership the mainstream islamic
leadership in those countries reaching
out to this minority and i say again
that this is a minority this is a fringe
this is not the mainstream of islam so
when the mainstream reached out these
people decommission their weapons they
disengage from violence and some of them
do radical eyes but others more or less
disengaged from violence for me that's a
you know that's a sign of the leadership
coming out of saying those days are over
translate that to al-qaeda it means I'm
an as oh ah hurry or I will yahia Ali be
or someone of that caliber saying
al-qaeda was relevant in the Afghan war
in today's world where you know the the
young activists have managed to
overthrow dictators without violence
there's no need for that sort of world
view of the neo jihad in the far jihad
at that point we can say yes the
intellectual ideas battle is over and
therefore actions will start to
disappear but in the absence of that and
in the presence of Asura have reissuing
bimonthly videos encouraging his people
to rock up in Somalia in Yemen in
Tunisia in Libya and now in Syria I
think it's just too soon and want to be
cautious and deal with the Beast for
what it is rather than what we hope it
should be
okay thanks yes hi my name is dr. Palmer
I'd like to thank you very much for a
very interesting presentation I have
several questions my first is a reminder
that next week is 9/11 again I looked
over what is going to be discussed on
campus and I thought is practically
nothing it's almost as if perhaps it's
just this campus is sleeping but it's
not going to take specific action in
some way my real question though is what
is happening with Iran and all of this
what are they doing and if you study
Egypt economically its hospital the
economy has to keep going down and down
practically nobody in their right mind
is going to decide to go on vacation in
Egypt now tourism is one of the major
industries and with the economy going
down in downtown and with various other
situations going the activity within the
Sinai and so on what which weighs 100
more sigh going is he really doing
anything
I think lames to be this lawless and
where do you see all of this heading
from what I hear and when I gather here
the only way it's going to go is to
major explosion and violence and you're
the first person I've heard who said
that a lot perhaps I meant that much
about it who said that a lot of what's
going on in Syria is really al-qaida
that's very frightening all of this is
terribly frightening and the furniture
thank you
I should just sort of caveat and what I
said earlier again by saying I'm not for
a moment suggesting that the the the
rebels in Syria don't have a legitimate
claim to overthrowing the government nor
am i saying that you know that the
rebels are al-qaeda far from it please
don't go away thinking that's what I'm
saying no I'm saying that it's I mean I
stand by what I wrote in the National
Review saying that you know al Qaeda has
a strong presence within the ranks of
the fighters the various brigades that
have been set up received Saudi Salafi
fighting and the Free Syrian Army has
not to this day flushed out to al-qaeda
elements within it it hasn't which is
thus far it's refused to do so and
that's just a point of fact and you know
the Syria continues to be a draw for
jihadis globally you know that's not to
say that al Qaeda is is now dominant
it's not but it's fair to say that the
Muslim Brotherhood is dominant within
the Syrian National Council that's no
secret everybody knows that but al Qaeda
isn't yet dominant but then you know al
Qaeda's game is never to be the
centerpiece never to be dominant but to
command and control for its agenda from
the fringes um 9/11 on campus I mean
that's over to you and what happens here
next week will occur or not Iran I I
don't really know much about Iran I have
to confess that it's not my area of
special ISM and all I can say on Iran is
it's not to be trusted and I'm not you
know I'm not there with others who think
Iran is about to bomb or nuke its
neighbors I'm not there yet I just I
haven't seen the evidence but then how
do you ever see the evidence of her of a
secretive program but my you know when
President Morsi of Egypt goes to Iran
for the first time this is the first you
know Egyptian president since 1979 that
visits
Iran and he talks about Syria and
Iranian state TV
interrelates that into Farsi as Bahrain
you know in other words you're being
disloyal to your guests words you're you
know you're lying you're misinterpreting
intentionally what he's saying that's
not cause for you know building up trust
you know that that's that just
vindicates all of us who are pessimistic
and distrustful of Iran's intentions
because you know this is not George Bush
speaking this is the Egyptian president
you know an Islamist who's there
condemning your ally Iran what do you do
you you know live translation you lie
you twist it you change the name of the
country to Bahrain I mean these are
government officials doing that so
that's not cause for trust so beyond
that I mean you know implications the
nuclear program the implications and
trusting Iranians and I you know forgive
me
but on Egypt and Morsi you're right on
the economics but they seem to have
applied for a four billion dollar aid
program with the IMF only three months
ago they were against it now they've
revisited their own criteria and they
seem to be welcoming that you're right
on tourism you're right on the lack of
foreign direct investment currency
reserves are drying up unemployment is
high tourism has been scared away you
arrived in all of those counts
where is Morsi heading the good news in
all of this is Morsi comes from the
trend within the Muslim Brotherhood
that's dominated by someone called Kyle
at a charter handfish Arthur is an
out-and-out capitalist you know
multi-millionaire deputy leader of the
Muslim Brotherhood owns many of the
malls inside Egypt and some of the
largest brand names very close to this
Turkish model so more interested in
capitalism than they're interested in
promoting 1960s socialist type Islamism
so there's good news on that front that
they do want to recuperate Egypt and
they do want to sort of build Egypt on
on strong economic footing and you know
from what I've heard from IMF officials
have visited them and other officials
from NGOs have gone spoken to the
economic team or the economics team of
the Muslim Brotherhood
they've come away more impressed with
that outfit than they have of some of
the more liberal left-leaning
organizations in town because when they
go and meet the secular organizations
the discussion is always about more aid
but with the Brotherhood it's been about
aid but also trade you know that keen to
build up the country's economy time will
tell whether they succeed or not but
what must has got going against him as
geopolitics you know what might happen
with Iran what might happen with with
with Syria with Israel on its borders
and one of the great things about the
Arab Spring thus far has been that it's
not been about destruction but about
construction it's been about building
their own countries and internal
grievances about within each country but
Arabs forgive me for saying so are an
emotional people generally you know and
when the arab-israeli conflict riles up
again as it inevitably will and it does
every five to six years and we're
crossing the five year mark after Gaza
you'll see Egyptians will get angry and
annoyed and some resort of flag burning
and you know heading towards the border
in Sinai and tackling the Israeli
embassy and you know the Muslim
Brotherhood will start to issue loud
noises the moment that happens you scare
away investors you scare away tourists
you bring economic damage to your
country and that's what I worry about
you know the arab-israeli issue flaring
up again and bringing damage to to Egypt
but thus far on balance yes merchants
don't want to you know three things
wrong from press freedoms to you know on
issues of the Constitution and whatnot
but that's far the good news is that
it's not been an extremist government
and those of those people in DC that
threatened that Brotherhood would be you
know immediately declaring war on Israel
tearing up the peace treaty and forcing
all the women to veil and forbidding the
banning of alcohol I mean they were
wrong and I think it will continue to be
wrong so unbalanced the jury's out but
thus far it seems to be good news right
now
what you just said and that history has
a way of taking it turns unexpectedly
but what seems to be your point is what
I'm getting from it is that these issues
in the Arab world in this region are
going to either be settled by Arabs
themselves that things will work out or
there will be some other force
there'll be some other than possibly an
external force maybe even the United
States and its policy that might have a
role in calming things down so I would
say in terms of your estimation in
American foreign policy do you think
that appears to be a based on the the
Democratic platform that was just
accepted that the United States is
pulling away from its commitments in the
Middle East and pivoting towards Asia
and do you think that if that continues
some of those issues and concerns in the
region Middle East
will get worse you can't introduce
yourself your good name excuse me I'm
Mel masking okay thank you I asked
because I often worry about trip
questions you know but the United States
of America
on the broad foreign policy question
must do what it what's right for the
United States of America the u.s. comes
first and one of the reasons why people
like me who aren't Americans that are
drawn to this country is because you
know this is the country in which
there's vibrant debate about you know
what it means to be American the
priorities of this country and what
makes this country great and anything
that compromises the greatness and you
know punctures the US confidence around
the world and us moral authority you
know whether there's in a short term in
the long term ought to be questioned and
to my mind you know if the Democratic
platform and Jerusalem and whatnot I
mean I don't want to go into that
because I just think you know it's it's
a local problem for the Arabs and
Israelis to sort out and it's not for a
power like this country to be getting
involved in the details off that part of
the world to that extent at this you
know in a pre-election setting but if it
is in the economic interests of the u.s.
to look more towards Asia than it should
and it's must the United States of
America comes first and that includes if
you you know I mean let's be blunt
Israel to look after itself you know
Israel has enough nuclear and other
weapons arsenals to defend itself on the
Arab Street Israel is feared regionally
it's a superpower and sixty years after
its modern founding what more can Israel
ask for if it has issues in terms of its
neighbors whether it's the difficulties
it has with the Sinai in Egypt or the
Golan Heights Israel should be talking
to its own neighbors you know and not
drawing in the authority of the US
repeatedly that then leads to the u.s.
being compromised in the eyes of you
know 300 million plus Arabs my
contention is this that if the US and
its goodness and his virtues are
understood and supported and accepted by
ordinary Arabs and Muslims in that part
of the world then the u.s. is a stronger
arbiter a stronger guarantor of Israeli
security in the region in other words
the US is seen as a friend of Arabs and
Muslims and before 1953 so in 1956 the
Suez Crisis the u.s. was seen as a
friend of Arabs and Muslims the u.s. in
1956 went against Britain against France
against Israel and sided with Egypt and
it had huge amounts of political capital
in the region if by siding by Israel
repeatedly and blocking you know UN
motions and being seen to be a biased
player in the region what the u.s. does
is it undermines its own credibility in
the region and therefore compromises
Israel's security too so if you want to
come to it in terms of Israel security
that say you know being on better terms
with the Arabs helps the u.s. help
Israel and you go the other way around
and you
week in the USU we can Israel and you
enrage people in the region and I'm not
sure who wins in any of this so you want
to come back I'm sure you've sort of you
look very frustrated you know the United
States we can then throw our friends
under the bus the friends can take care
of themselves our allies and let's walk
away from the situation the United
States has to make choices every country
makes choice in terms of foreign policy
and if the United States walked away
from its commitments in the Middle East
do you think the Arabs would say well
you know things now we could accept the
existence of Israel we could accept US
bases on the Arabian Peninsula and
everything is going to be fine and dandy
can't we all get along I don't know if
that's gonna be the case I think that
just might strengthen them and encourage
them a little more to take action thank
you
Shirley thanks for the sort of response
and I you know III appreciate where
you're coming from but I mean I'd say
this and I'm not so rebutting what
you're saying I respect your position
but anti-americanism isn't as widespread
in countries such as Saudi Arabia when I
was there about 12 weeks ago you know I
was with the President of the Council
Richard Haass and I was shocked by the
level of warm welcome across Saudi
society and even there again and again
you know three points came up and I
don't want to go into the detail but one
of them was you know the perceived bias
of the United States toward Israel and
to question you know Israel's relations
in the region is not to throw it under
the bus is not to abandon it but to
build better relations with its
neighbors in order to ultimately help
strengthen it anyhow you know we differ
on this and I see where you're coming
from you promised you were on coming
from but you know we agree to disagree
I am a Muslim very much and but I was
born here in America and I am thinking
that you were born in England yep and I
wanted to commiserate with you as a
Muslim - Muslim I am that we'd kept
America lolli but I use my name Kevin
Barrett because in this society and
moving around it's very difficult to be
but that would be lovely
so my business and everything I do is
Kevin Barrett and I was just I have a
couple of questions and I was just
curious in your situation or it may be
dilemma why you changed your name from
mohamed hussein to IDI Hussain I also
wanted to ask about your perspective of
this feared state called the Caliphate
and the establishment of a Caliphate
that as for Muslims is something that
Muslims are not afraid of and I don't
know how many Muslims come to events
like this and present themselves and
because I came here to Peter Birdman's
Bergin's presentation and I didn't I'm
always hearing one side and this is a
place of freedom when the freedoms that
we all enjoy and I wanted to at least be
part of another side to this
and the establishment of the Caliphate
is almost as year to Muslims as is
everything about Islam
having a leadership and having some kind
of direction in this world that has a
lot of what I see as the beginnings of
moral decline and you talked about what
level of Wilber up which is a concept
that says that this state this place is
for Muslims and maybe only for Muslims
as is the job and pajamas which is the
Mecca and Medina and you called it you
said that if this was established we
become an international ghetto those
were your words and I just wanted you to
expound upon
concept of or idea that a Muslim world
that that was not pluralistic in second
secular in its extent would become an
international ghetto you also mentioned
that at the end of your presentation
that this would prevent something about
preventing the spread of this virus and
I think that you're talking about Islam
or jihadism or terrorism or I don't know
what do you think anything I'm talking
about Islam as a virus no but you okay
well I say that then I mean I see
because the Muslim not afraid of an
Islamic state I'm not an accept like
Egypt is happening right now
it is where the New York Times that the
people are women are starting to become
work with a job and wearing clothing
that is prescribed by the religion or
social agencies or I mean that the
spread of equality means is going all
throughout Egypt and you know all these
signs all these things to me said that
there's going to be eventually an
establishment of a counterfeit or an
establishment of all these countries
coming together between Turkey which has
already changed despite Kemal atatrk
things change of the mindset of the
people there that they're going back to
Islam and I just wanted you to maybe
express those two statements at least
and maybe also why there is such a fear
of an Islamic state in Islamic
perspective in the world you know okay
where to begin but let's start with the
first question first the personal
element um my name I mean on my passport
on the official document still is
Muhammad Husain I'm not ashamed of it
I'm not afraid of it but my contention
is this that if Antony can become Tony
Mohammed can become ed if Andhra can
become Andy Mohammed can become moe
you know you might want to ask my Fuhrer
the Olympic winner in England you know
of Somalia extract why he shortened his
name from Mohammed to Moe I don't think
it's just the shortening of the name and
I don't think it's a big deal I don't
think we should read too much into it
and you know this is this is the land in
which people have their initials as
their names you know a B Cheevers goes
as you know Andrey bow and Chibs goes
with a B Cheevers and whatnot so
it's just a personal preference and you
know honestly I just I just don't think
it's making a statement about the West
or Islamophobia or anything along those
lines it's just a preference to have the
name shortened rather than you know how
many Muhammad's are there in this world
just all too many so to shorten it to a
dis sorry yeah and some people might not
necessarily want to be you know when I
was in Mecca
honestly I now lived in Jeddah and when
I was in Mecca you know people say yeah
Mohammad and at least 15 people would
turn around you know it's just is that's
all it is you know I'm not making any
more of it as a big deal than a toast
you know that's all it is so having put
that to bed Muslims are not afraid of
the Islamic state I'm not so sure about
that and I'll say this for the following
reasons we should distinguish between
two things one Islam the religion and
two Islamism the political ideology
Islam the religion goes back to the time
of the Prophet Muhammad to my mind it's
you know the Prophet Muhammad
contemplated meditated in Mecca on in
the hard here at the time in a mountain
much like Buddha and others contemplated
you know in that part of the world and
what he received his interaction with
Gabriel to my mind is the finalization
of the interaction that Abraham Moses
Adam Jesus and others had and you know
he was part of the Abrahamic tradition I
mean I am Sunni Muslims and I have no
qualms about that and I'm as proud as
can be about that but at the same time
that tradition that he left behind it
was a spiritual pathway he spoke about
you know the afterlife the vast majority
of the Quranic injunctions are about
kindness and forgiveness and humanity
and whatnot and you know those themes
are universal but something happens in
history you know various understandings
of Islam and what Islamism is but for
for our purposes what I would you know
impeach on you to do is to distinguish
between Islam the faith the religion you
know from the Quran Sunnah hadith and
and you know the various readings of its
own is Shia a Sufi and whatnot and then
look at the modern islamist project you
know from hassan al-banna news writing
to madhu these writings to say it's part
of the writings to Nabhan is writing to
have the salon farad is writing then to
where the extremes al-qaeda have ended
up in other words
limbs are not Apple it was lence art a
faith community that we are a political
bloc you know this was in response to
Karl Marx's language of the the
bourgeois versus the proletariat the
global workers rising you know so module
this project was you know global Muslim
Omar rising historically Muslims have
never been united as one or my it's the
one of largest myths that were told I
mean look at the suffer we look at the
Mughals look at the Ottomans and beyond
they were fighting one another the
prophet's own grandchildren were at war
we can go into the details for as much
as you want but the bottom line is this
whole notion that muslims are a
political bloc and they united together
as a political bloc is cloud cuckoo-land
thinking it never existed in history and
it won't happen in the future
indonesian x' have very little in common
with turks and turks have very little
common with Yemenis and Yemenis in
return have very little in common with
same Muslims from the subcontinent
so therefore to think that this is some
kind of future project which we should
all be working towards that some kind of
Muslim global domination and then
subjugating the rest of the world some
kind of jihad and onslaught we've been
there with the gates of Vienna we saw
the damage that it did for me now the
reality is this that Muslims are not
going back to that world where we are
living as a pluralist modern globalized
interdependent world and in that our
role and I say this to you as a fellow
Muslim from a Sharia point of view is to
embrace the Mikasa the Sharia arguments
which is that Sharia and you know John
Locke was influenced by these arguments
that were articulated but even our short
and their own before that by you know
the amendment had Maine and others that
you know and those of you who haven't
thought about this you might want to
look at this that you know and I used to
write a blog called the Arab Street and
I've written about it on this blog post
that you know the Sharia was
historically to guarantee five things
you know human life property the mind or
the intellect and family and there was
one other point which I forget now so
the Sharia was there to defend those
five things now there was a whole body
of legal jurisprudence in the 13th
century in North Africa before that
Cazalas teacher wrote about this Makaha
the Sharia that some claim you know the
codification of this influence John
Locke and John Locke's did teacher in in
Oxford Pocock studied in Damascus so
there is a serious
line of thought intellectual tradition
here from Muslims codifying MacArthur
Sharia to Pocock to Locke - then
Jefferson and others here and you may
question it but my appeal to Muslims has
embraced that tradition of you know live
and let live and coexistence rather than
confrontation and domination because
that world is over and if we want to
head towards that without world be my
guess but anticipate war and its
consequences the other point you raised
about international ghettos I mean any
community that thinks it's going to sort
of close in on itself and cut itself off
from the rest of the world to my mind is
a ghettoization I was born in London my
parents came from British India I now
live in New York I travel across you
know the world I want that world to be
as it is and I want to protect that
world as it is in other words
interdependent globalized and I don't
think most Muslims in the Arab world
actually would want to sort of create
some kind of Arab Arab state for
themselves the evidence for that is I
find when I go to Israel Israelis are
more concerned about what's going on in
Syria out of empathy apathy and other
reasons then my Egyptian friends are at
the moment you know because Egyptians
have far bigger issues on their own
plates so you know I I'd sort of you
know beg of you to sort of you know
rethink Islam versus Islamism and modu
this tradition was influenced by Marxism
said quote it was influenced by
communism they were struggling between
capitalism and communism and they came
up with something called Islamism
traditional Islam is much more forgiving
tolerant pluralistic and the mufasa the
Sharia arguments helps us I think come
to terms of modernity as it is and we
should embrace that for our own benefit
but for the benefit of our own children
and those that come after them
hello my name is Tanya progeria and I'm
asking this question looking and died it
was what you suggest the solution should
be and which is how do we mean from here
and I was trying to understand not to
conflate Islam and radical Islam so my
questions about what you claim is the
whole ideology that started in around
1953 and from that time onwards and
perhaps had no reason to have currency
then and yet somehow for whatever reason
still seems to have growing currency
you're still persisting currency in
various parts of the Arab world and I
don't understand why but I was trying to
understand whether you can whether
ideology flourishes in and of itself for
no reason at all or whether it's rooted
in actual ground realities and in that
sense if we do not understand why it is
becoming popular in some places today
will we ever be able to solve the
problem just by say ridiculous or making
fun of these ideologies and just and I
ask this from a perspective because I
come from India where also in many ways
radical Islamic I guess are on the rise
in some quarters but the response to be
more and more hatred and fear is only
making the problem worse because you do
neglect the fact that if you look at
certain what facts do some communities
in the country do not do that well so
they are less employed in government
they're economically for our literacy
rates are lower so I'm just trying to
say that ideology and certain radical
ideologies in my experience are more
rooted in areas when people have very
real grievances and I don't see the
problem being solved by just ridiculous
here I guess without tackling sure the
see what you allude to is true that
socio-economic grievances are part of
the story you know but say you know you
know comparing Muslims in Europe for
example or Muslims here many of them
aren't of a sort of socioeconomically
deprived background and yet among upper
echelons of certain extremist Islamist
groups that same ideology resonates
because I
while socioeconomic factors are one
factor it doesn't always explain you
know why Muslims say in London who are
bankers accountants engineers lecturers
at you know elite universities why is it
that they've embraced that same ideology
you know yet no they're not working
towards jihad but they're certainly sort
of entertained this you know a radical
confrontational them in ass worldview
and recruit students towards smaller
meetings or cell structure meetings so
the socio-economic factor is doesn't
always explain everything I think there
are several other factors that play
although I'm not taking what you've said
away from you I think that's important
the other factors are as follows Bernard
Lewis I'm not always given to quoting
professor Lewis but I think on this
instance it's worth hearing him out on
this he made a very powerful point when
he said historically most Muslims around
the world throughout history have been
in a position of power so where there
was the moguls in India a minority but
yet in power in India for all 300 plus
years before the British arrived or
whether it's the Ottoman Turks across
the Arab world or whether it's the
Safavids in Persia or you know in
Tatarstan where Muslim minorities were
in positions of power wherever you look
historically large groups of Muslims
were always in a position of power even
when they were in a minority India being
a case a case in point so what's
happened is after the end of Empires
Muslims haven't yet adjusted to a
position of citizenship you know a
position of being first among equals if
that you know there is yet this mental
complex of wanting to dominate wanting
to be in power wanting to impose on
others what we think is correct you know
for ourselves
both religiously and politically and now
that I see that playing out in Pakistan
in a big way you know this complex of my
form of Islam is only right and I must
dominate even among Muslims you know
this this desire there are exceptions to
that in India is an interesting
exception where you know the works of
Jose Mohammed
than he and others show us that Indian
Muslims might be heading towards a
different trajectory based on that
mentality of wanting to dominate to
digit to rule to govern a sense of that
we have the best form of government we
have the best understanding of what the
afterlife consists off the neglect of
that leads to the second point which is
you know not being in that position of
power not being a superpower globally
which was beaten which has been the
Muslim trajectory for the last thousand
years
not being in a position of you know
equality with other superpowers but
there was the you know the Austrian
Habsburg Empire whether it was the
British Empire whether it was the you
know the the Byzantines on their last
days as the the Omar Wiis were rising
whatever the the the the the point of
contest is if Muslims aren't in a
position of power there's a feeling
sometimes of humiliation you know we
were once powerful we ought to be
powerful if we're not powerful it's it's
it's it's a lana from god it's a curse
from god and we feel collectively
humiliated in in in the in the rise of
the West or the rise of China but more
the rise of the West so to correct that
humiliation then we must then plan for
an equal form of Muslim rising of Muslim
unity that then counters the West you
know better still overtakes the West or
at least confronts the West you know so
what you see is an imitation a shallow
level of imitation of you know if it's
coca-cola it scribbler Cola if it's
capitalist banking its Islamic banking
if it's a bikini it becomes a burqini
you know if it's if it's if it's General
Motors then it becomes an Islamic car in
Iran
why is the car Islamic because you've
got a glove compartment in which you can
put your you know I mean I can go on you
switch the car on an Islamic prayer
comes on so give me key form of Islam
which isn't rooted in tradition or depth
or intellectual intensity so so there is
that you know the humiliation and the
desire to compete and therefore the
radical ideology offers solutions to
this it offers an office seat as serious
answers to these questions of
existential angst to this collective
feeling of humility of humiliation
the third factor that there is
a lot of money involved in the prophet
Isaiah of this ideology Saudi Arabia and
the universities of Mecca and Medina and
their graduates earn a living out of
being advocates for that worldview many
of them have abandoned the the jihadi
element but they're believed to Al Hilal
bara and Philip and Sharia as I
maintained and the last point in also do
I can see Matt giving me the look you
know go back to the audience the last
point is identity you know and it's most
of us Muslims you know haven't come to
terms with the modern world for what it
is you know there is that desire deep
within us that you know we're with you
know my generation of Muslims you know
we're first-generation sort of second
generation in Europe you know many of
the Muslims here in America are sort of
second third generation American Muslims
and I think of all the countries have
visited American Muslim seem most to be
comfortable with their you know with
with with being Muslim here
notwithstanding what you said earlier
when I compared to say European
countries and that same identity crisis
of what it means to be Muslim today what
it means to be Arab what it means to be
Pakistan is playing out today as we
speak in in Pakistan and in the Arab
world and in the absence of a clear
you know scripturally rooted relevant to
the modern world answer to what it means
to be a modern Muslim the old narratives
still hold sway because they're the ones
with the answers that say you're not an
Arab you're not an Egyptian you're not a
Pakistani you're a Muslim full stop that
identity comes first your responsibility
is not to integrate into the modern
world but to separate and to create your
own block that's caught that confronts
your responsibilities to call the rest
of the world to our form of Islam is the
only true form of Islam there is answer
the convincing if you don't know you
know an alternative tradition on which
you can stand so I advance those answers
as you know you know several causes as
to why radical ideology can be
compelling for people okay thank you
that
I think Jason you have the last question
described in great detail on how
Islamist movements and I'm wondering if
you could talk a little bit about the
mentality of the people who join if you
notice any similarities you know what
what what what do Islamist what do
things wrong on when they're looking for
people to recruit and what is um good
question and in terms of what is it
about their rhetoric that resonates you
know against several things come to mind
one is that what was fascinating for me
to see in London but also then more
recently in Egypt and travels in other
parts of the Muslim struck Arab world is
and this goes against conventional
wisdom but I think the research by
people like Marc Sageman has made this
point and I mean I saw this firsthand in
the 1990s people who were religiously
rooted in other words if you were an
observant Muslim and I'm not talking
about the modern robotic form of just
you know you know just praying five
times a day and doing a rituals and you
know just taking off the boxes like an
accountant and hoping to land in heaven
one day not that kind of Islam but the
Islam of the old Islam of our parents
generation that was inherently spiritual
that was that called towards you know
veneration of the old that that that
valued poetry of Rumi of half years of
hiam of the Cabal even in in Pakistan
that that drew towards the Sufi mystical
traditions that resonate inside Islam
now for their 1,300 years that believed
in miracles that honored the the shrines
of saints as a place that was holy that
looked towards people of other faiths as
brothers and sisters of the same
Abrahamic tradition and if they were
Hindus and others that they were also
people who had a you know had a
religious tradition that ought to be
recognized much much like the lines of
say Dara Shikoh in India
that kind of Islam you know the the
mainstream Indian Hanif Islam or the
mainstream Islam of the Egyptian Sufis
or which happens to be the mainstream
Islam in in in in in Egypt but also in
Syria in Jordan in Yemen that kind of
coexist tential historical rooted
scriptural orthodox traditional Islam
you know that that can accommodate the
modern world
now that form of Islam and those who are
exposed to that Islam those who grew up
in that form of Islam and that don't I
understood Scripture from that point of
view were less reluctant were less given
to joining extremist groups and if they
did they left very quickly because they
realized what they were being sold was a
new project or they were being told
about was a political idea what they
wanted essentially from these groups was
you know activism not contemplation not
worship but activism so you know
immediate those people would last a year
two years if they joined and they
quickly withdraw so religion is to my
mind an antidote to that worldview and
it's I've seen that play out over and
over again and if you look at in
Pakistan or India or in the Arab
subcontinent in the Arab world those who
have a religious education rarely join
and the evidence for that is look at the
leaders of these groups whether it's the
Muslim Brotherhood or others very few of
them are clerics because they know that
these are modern in of innovative
movements that are responding to you
know the the ideological battles of our
time that's the first point
religious routing tends tends to keep
people away and people in those groups
who weren't necessarily of a genuine of
genuine religiosity and when I do I know
secondly when I joined what I saw inside
many of those groups of people who
couldn't read the Quran people who
didn't know their basics in terms of
religion but were very keen to be
talking about politics and a third point
that I'd make is that most of the people
that are drawn towards these groups are
drawn on university campuses now more in
prisons and whatnot but in those days at
least and still in Arab world in on
university campuses and normally
students who are studying engineering
and medicine you know and again look at
mark statements work and look at the the
profile of the leaders of most of these
groups that they have PhDs in
engineering or their medical doctors you
know so what that means is approaching
scripture from a instructive point of
view in other words you know do don't
it's like a DIY manual if you do a you
get B you get c you know formulaic
formulaic islam in other words metaphor
poetry contexts
you know nuance caveats scholarship of
the past all that gets lost as you do in
a liberal education so that was another
sort of interesting point that research
is proven but what you know once saw
inside those groups and the final point
would be this identity people had an
identity crisis joined those groups are
accepting the narrative more readily
inside egypt those who came from the
countryside into Cairo or Alexandria
more readily joined the Muslim
Brotherhood and jihadi groups afterwards
than those who are already in their
cities or those who had a more rooted
scent of their own own worth or identity
and weren't moving in the class
structure trying to move upwards anyhow
alright well thank you so much again
everything those Griffin
just say one last thing since this is
our last event this summer we're going
to be gathering again next summer for a
whole series of lectures also a research
program on climate change in global
governance so those of you if your
students and that sounds interesting to
you then do keep that in mind and it's
something you might be interested in and
you'll be hearing more about it and and
obviously I hope you'll apply if that
interest you and and those you just like
to come to our lectures we're very happy
to have you and so I hope you'll join us
again next summer so thank you again and
thank you